the world is filled with data a lot of
data pictures music words spreadsheets
videos and it doesn't look like it's
going to slow down anytime soon
machine learning brings the promise of
deriving meaning from all of that data
arthur c clarke famously once said any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
I've found machine learning not to be
magic but rather tools and technology
and you can utilize to answer questions
with your data this is cloud AI
adventures my name is Yu Feng Guo and
each episode we will be exploring the
art science and tools of machine
learning along the way we'll see just
how easy it is to create amazing
experiences and yield valuable insights
the value of machine learning is only
just beginning to show itself there's a
lot of data in the world today generated
not only by people but also by computers
phones and other devices this will only
continue to grow in the years to come
traditionally humans have analyzed data
and adapted systems to the changes in
data patterns however as the volume of
data surpasses the ability for humans to
make sense of it and manually write
those rules we will turn increasingly to
automated systems that can learn from
the data and importantly the changes in
data to adapt to a shifting landscape we
see machine learning all around us in
the products we use today however it
isn't always apparent that machine
learning is behind it all while things
like tagging objects and people inside
of photos are clearly machine learning
at play it may not be immediately
apparent that recommending the next
video to watch is also powered by
machine learning of course perhaps the
biggest example of all is Google search
every time you use Google search you're
using a system that has many machine
learning systems at its core from
understanding the text of your query to
adjusting the results based on your
personal interests such as knowing which
results to show you first when searching
for Java depending on whether you're a
coffee expert or developer perhaps
you're both today machine learnings
immediate applications are already quite
wide-ranging you
including image recognition fraud
detection and recommendation systems as
well as text and speech systems to these
powerful capabilities can be applied to
a wide range of fields from diabetic
retinopathy and skin cancer detection to
retail and of course transportation in
the form of south parking and
self-driving vehicles it wasn't that
long ago that when a company or product
had machine learning in its offerings it
was considered novel now every company
is pivoting to use machine learning in
their products in some way it's rapidly
becoming well an expected feature just
as we expect companies to have a website
that works on your mobile device or
perhaps an app the day will soon come
when it will be expected that our
technology will be personalized
insightful and self-correcting as we use
machine learning to make human tasks
better faster and easier than before we
can also look further into the future
when machine learning can help us do
tasks that we never could have achieved
on our own thankfully it's not hard to
take advantage of machine learning today
the tooling has gotten quite good all
you need is data developers and a
willingness to take the plunge for our
purposes I've shortened the definition
of machine learning
that's just five words using data to
answer questions while I wouldn't use
such a short answer for an essay prompt
on an exam it serves a useful purpose
for us here in particular we can split
the definition into two parts using data
and answer questions these two pieces
broadly outline the two sides of machine
learning both of them equally important
using data is what we were referred to
as training well answering questions is
referred to as making predictions or
inference now let's drill into those two
sides briefly for a little bit training
refers to using our data to inform the
creation and fine-tuning of a predictive
model this predictive model can then be
used to serve up predictions on
previously unseen data and answer those
questions as more data is gathered the
model can be improved over time and new
predictive models deployed as you may
have noticed the key component of this
entire process
is data everything hinges on data data
is the key to unlocking machine learning
just as much as machine learning is the
key to unlocking that hidden insight in
data this was just a high-level overview
of machine learning why it's useful and
some of its applications machine
learning is a broad field spanning an
entire family of techniques were
inferring answers from data so in future
episodes William to give you a better
sense of what approaches to use for a
given data set and question you want to
answer as well as provide the tools for
how to accomplish it and in our next
episode we'll dive right into the
concrete process of doing machine
learning in more detail going through a
step by step formula for how to approach
machine learning problems
[Music]